[Music]
hi I'm Deidre Bay and I'm Katy Kraus and
there's no denying the weather forecast
for 2017 was extremely shady oh so shady
so much shade which is why we are
running down at the shadiest moments of
the year the shadiest alleged feud of
the year was between Katy Perry and
Taylor Swift are you ready for
swish-swish-swish 2017 is finally when
Katy Perry addressed the feud because
she could not stop talking about Taylor
Swift while promoting her album
witness mind you Taylor Swift has never
even acknowledged or said anything about
Katy Perry she's always let the music do
the talking so on swish-swish everyone
assumed it to be their response to bad I
[Music]
mean she told Taylor that she should
retire the girlfriend has sold over 3
million albums of reputation and that's
what I have to say about I do give Katy
Perry credit for extending the olive
branch take a look at this clip I
forgive her and I'm sorry for anything I
ever did and I hope the same from her
and I I think it's actually like I think
it's time I really truly want to come
together and within a place of love and
forgiveness and understanding and
compassion ok and I do agree with you I
think that she was trying to take the
high road but I also think there's
something to be said about needing to
promote an album and she could not stop
talking about this feud with Taylor
Swift fans wanted to know but I do think
it's interesting that Taylor has not
said anything on witness release day the
day the album was out Taylor did sort of
comment by releasing all of her albums
to streaming services shading that was
again letting the music do the talking
it's brilliant marketing you know
speaking of brilliant marketing look
what you made me
comes out we think that we're gonna get
a response to chock-full of little
nuggets all over it people assume that
this once seen in the video is perhaps a
nod to Katy Perry you having the wind
the costume so final thoughts on this
feud I'm very proud to be a woman in
2017 I think more than anything
both Taylor and Katy despite any
differences they might have they're
willing to put that behind them there's
enough room at the top I'm with you I
don't think that there's a few we need
to talk about yeah girl power
I do feel like that beef is squashed we
can move on
Taylor's happy she says she's doing
better than she ever was Katy has this
new gig on American Idol and they think
2018 is going to be an incredible year
for both of them
love it next up
fifth harmony and Camila Cabello who
used to be in fifth harmony she of
course exited the band last December so
it's been about a year but this year
there's been some turmoil some moments
between the girls and it's hurt my heart
but I do think now maybe oh that's you
know under the rug and that they're okay
but let's kind of break down what's been
going on it all started in 2015 when
Camila did a song with Shawn Mendes and
we actually asked her about the breakup
rumors back then take a look
lots of Harmonizers freaked out today
and they thought you guys were breaking
up obviously any band any group someday
is not going to be together anymore like
that's just you know that's just like
yeah that's a life that's just you know
the truth I think anybody kind of knows
that whether you say it or not but like
we're working on your music for you guys
right now everything's good you know be
happy so we assumed it things were good
weren't splitting I mean she did say
something you know bands can't last
forever know that and she kind of
foreshadow that I respect that yeah
course Justin Timberlake wasn't gonna be
an adapting forever but they told us
that there was a new album coming so
fast forward to 2016
Katy again with the girls I'm a
harmonizer what can I say - uh you asked
them about again these breakup rumors -
take a look what it had to say how did
that affect you guys and what kind of
conversations happen
we are coming out with an album now so
there you go that's what happened with
that on its swing at the end of the day
cuz May 20th you gotta not look at me
yeah we got a song out on the radio
right now I mean is definitely our first
love
so probably always been the foundation
of everything so regardless of
everything that's going on we've always
always been focused harmony I think a
lot of people's awareness was really
heightened at the VMAs fifth harmony
performed and there was a fifth figure
on the stage that magically got tossed
off a lot of people assume that too bad
[ __ ] that's Shady
Camilla yeah and then we were with
Camilla not long ago and we asked her
about being on the Jingle Ball tour
which the fifth harmony girls are also
on here's what she said what is it like
being back on tour with the girls this
is kind of the first time you guys have
been back together is it fun a little
break in Dili
I haven't even I haven't seen them no no
no I haven't so cookies I'm saying fair
to note that the Jingle Ball tour they
weren't on all the dates together and we
actually heard that Lauren and Camilla
were hanging out backstage or they at
least spoke backstage and that just
warms my heart so it seems like again
girls against girls we can all just come
together there doesn't need to be this
feud they can all go on pursue their own
passion they can release albums together
I think we can be supportive of all of
them at the end of the day absolutely
Lauren has a song with Steve Aoki with
Halsey and just to rewind the Spice
Girls didn't exactly love each other
when they split up and now they're the
best of friends I have full faith in my
heart the fifth harmony the og squad is
gonna come out yeah
all right our third and final shadiest
feud of the year we've got the
Kardashians versus Caitlyn Jenner now
this one really hurts my heart because
things were peachy keen and this is
family that we're talking about here
family okay so usually blood is thicker
than water not necessarily in this case
so initially when Bruce Jenner announced
he was transitioning into Caitlyn Jenner
the Kardashians were extremely
supportive they went to every one of her
events the ESPYs Caitlyn was still on
the show at that point about still
filming things unfortunately took a
really nasty turn in 2017 when Caitlyn
decided to release her memoir yes it is
so shady
that Caitlyn came over and gave me the
book and then on the phone she said well
the final version has a few more things
in it but don't worry it's nothing about
you so she lied to me so here's kind of
what happened basically she gave every
family member a copy of the memoir
before its release and they all seemed
peachy keen with it okay with it but
then they documented this actually on
their reality show that many of the
excerpts in the book that was published
were taken out of the copies that they
received and Caitlyn made some comments
about their dad Rob Kardashian and Kim
said this I have always had Caitlyn's
back but she is a liar to sell a book
you're gonna make something up if this
is the way that someone feels about me
after 23 years I choose to be the bigger
person what are the chances of your mom
Kris and Caitlyn ever speaking again to
2% and those are Kendall and Kylie I
think the only thing that I am holding
out hope for is that Kylie's alleged
pregnancy is gonna hopefully reunite the
family and nothing happier than a baby
right yeah and I think that as the Year
winds down and we do have three members
of that family pregnant seemingly
pregnant yes
um Kim Khloe and Kylie and all
relatively soon I think that hopefully
that maybe brings Kalyn back
into the mix I would hopefully think at
least with Kylie's situations so many
feuds in 2017 which one hit you the
hardest you know as much as I love
talking about this I kind of also hate
it because I just want there to be love
and positivity and I think that it's a
new chapter in 2018 its 2017 this is a
woman's world we need to yah and stick
together right now and there's climb in
with what's going on support each other
there's enough success at the top we can
all just hug it out and agree to love
each other right it's already this is
too sappy it's really how I feel me too
anyways thank you guys for watching and
Happy New Year holidays
[Music]